you mentioned um the debt ceiling a
little bit ago you guys are about to
vote on a debt ceiling in the next four
months so I my whole life I've been
watching them incrementally raise the
debt ceiling over and over and over and
the thing is it's from my point of view
it's supposed to be a ceiling that you
don't print more money than that because
that's the ceiling so can we like make a
realistic debt ceiling of like 1.4
quadrillion just say we're gonna get
there eventually we we can survive this
amount we're gonna print another 7 000
trillion dollars
um because I think we are going to I
don't know do you think maybe we won't
um do what do you think about that idea
is that just too far out when he went in
well you're you're right that it's it's
a joke because there is no real plan to
ensure that we have a cap on that which
we will borrow and spend and I think the
reason this continues to get worse on
the books is because like regular
Americans don't feel the pain of the
national debt in approximate way like